the main problem was when i read the
script that he said that he had a limp
this bloke he was like uh he was
pretending to be a war hero she had a
walking stick and a limp and i was like
i've not you know i've done bits about
him i didn't know how you do a limp
that's not like
i mean it's accents first wow the barber
set very low here
yeah you've probably been to acting
school yeah did they do limp the first
turn
a whole year
so i didn't know but so but then when i
was getting the costume fitted the bloke
in there went to me i was saying i don't
have to olympia i don't know what i
think i've got a bit obsessed on the
limb i didn't think i needed to
he said though the trick is if you get a
stone and put it in your shoe
you're not in oscar nominated
garfield
so what you do is you put a stone in and
then you've always got the exact same
limp because you're literally giving
yourself a limp because it's in the same
position so it'll be consistent because
that's the key to acting as we know
andrew
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
this took me a year to figure all the
stuff out in like one day i know yeah
i'm a very quick learner so watch
yourself
so i had to stone him but when i get
there and i speak to the director i was
like yeah the limp sorted don't worry
we're all it's all good and then she
went oh she doesn't he doesn't actually
have a limp he's lying about his injury
so the limp needs to be inconsistent
no
yeah no indeed don't fret so now
i've got a consistent limp
so now my acting i'm doing about eight
different acting jobs
i've got the pervert roll going on
i've got the stone in my shoe so now i'm
having to try and act like i haven't got
a limp even though i have got a limb
i've made it much harder and the worst
part is all of this you never see me
walk
never seen
[Music]
you